part of the blair witch mania that took
hold in the years following the film's
release was due to its ambiguous ending
what did it mean was the tragic fate
that befell the three aspiring
filmmakers a supernatural one or was it
something more human
let's investigate the most popular
theories surrounding the abrupt ending
of the blair witch project
the backstory to the blair witch project
included the relationships between its
fictional filmmakers heather donahue
joshua leonard and michael williams
josh's backstory included a previous
relationship with heather
and they'd worked together on a few
documentaries prior to blair witch
this makes it all the more upsetting for
heather when josh vanishes from their
tent
after a particularly depressing day when
the group hiked for hours
only to end up in the same place mike
and heather's first night alone turns
even darker when they hear
josh screaming in agony but can't locate
him
josh
is over here no it's over here
production designer ben rock explained
that josh had been taken to record the
screams in a studio
and they were then played for heather
and michael in the woods
heather wakes up to find a strange
bundle of sticks outside of her tent
inside the bundle was a swatch
of josh's actual flannel shirt a lock of
his hair
and what was meant to be josh's teeth
which rock confirmed were
actual human teeth that producer greg
hale got from a dentist
the bundle also ties the torture of josh
to other blair witch mythology which
claims that
in 1825 a ten-year-old child was seen
being pulled
into tappy east creek near burkittsville
maryland
the film's website explains that her
body was never recovered and
13 days after the drowning the creek is
clogged with oily bundles of sticks
on the second night following josh's
disappearance heather and mike come to a
strange house in the woods
the film's directors and writers daniel
myrick and eduardo sanchez
explained that according to blair witch
lore something really dramatic happens
in those woods every 40 to 50 years
the timeline of the lore begins in 1785
when ellie kedward is accused of
witchcraft by a group of children
kedward is found guilty and banished to
the woods to die during a harsh winter
following this event strange events take
place in the woods
including the modern case of the
burkittsville seven in 1940
seven children were reported missing
from the town of burkittsville formerly
known as blair
and are found buried in the cellar of
town resident rustin parr
parr is later executed for his crimes
based on the testimony of kyle brody a
child who managed to escape
these deaths are mentioned early in the
blair witch project when heather
interviews
locals about the legend in describing
that part of the shoot sanchez confirmed
that the house was meant to be
parr's house in both the blair witch
documentaries within the movie
parr confesses to the killings
that voice was by all accounts the blair
witch
mike charges into the par house while
recording yelling to josh and
encouraging heather to follow him
we see mike and heather's points of view
sweep over the house which only becomes
more unsettling as they encounter
strange symbols written on the walls
the symbols are from an alphabet known
as transitus fluviai
which is from a book of occult
philosophy that's supposedly practiced
by
you guessed it witches ben rock
confirmed that the creative team on the
blair witch project used this to
decorate the par house
the letters also pop up in the sci-fi
fictional special the curse of the blair
witch
which was aired to promote the release
of the blair witch project during the
tale of coffin rock
the mythology explains that coffin rock
is the site where a search party sent
out after a missing girl in 1886 were
brutally killed
according to the film archivist chris
carrasco and the curse of the blair
witch
the strange symbols aren't the only
creepy image decorating par's house
heather and mike's cameras revealed
dozens of child-sized handprints all
over the crumbling walls
these were obviously left behind by pars
victims all of which were children
rock said dan had the idea for the kids
hand prints from one time he'd gone to
someone's filthy house and their dogs
had made a giant black smear at dog
height throughout the house
for the actual movie the hand prints
were made using black paint applied to
the hands of art director ricardo
moreno's young nephews
it's one of the most memorable moments
from the blair witch project along with
heather's up the nose camera confession
after running downstairs heather's
camera swings around to reveal mike
standing in the corner of the basement
with his back to her
despite her blood-curdling screams he
doesn't move this final frame of the
film left audiences scratching their
heads
leaving artisan entertainment the
company that purchased the blair witch
project at the sundance film festival
only hours after its debut for 1.1
million dollars
afraid that the ending was too confusing
myrick later told entertainment weekly
when we screened it people were
overwhelmingly confused however when
asked if they were scared
19 out of 20 hands went up originally
there was no explanation for why mike
remained frozen in the corner
under pressure from artisan the team did
some reshoots in maryland and added
interviews in which townspeople talk
about
rust and par and the disappearance of
the original burkittsville 7.
the interviews alluded to the idea that
par made the children face the wall
so as to not witness the horrors
inflicted on their fellow victims
so what really happened in the end
there's no definitive answer and the
filmmakers
intended it that way director eduardo
sanchez said
there's no rhyme or reason to what's
happening in those woods you were never
meant to know
one theory suggests the filmmakers are
actually victims of the burkittsville
townspeople
after two nights in the woods heather
and josh discuss the unexplained sounds
they've been hearing at night saying
nobody knows we're out here yeah but you
ever see
deliverance referring to the 1972 film
deliverance
in which a group of men are stalked in
the woods by deranged locals
in a deleted scene included on the blair
witch dvd release
josh proposes that locals they
encountered in town during filming
are making a game of stalking the team
and that this
is the cause of the strange incidents
fans of this theory suggest
mike is standing in the corner at the
end because he's being held at gunpoint
by an
unseen person while heather is then
knocked out others say that mary brown
the strange woman interviewed at the
start of the film
is one of these people as the wooden
gate to her mobile home looks similar to
both the stick figures
and the bundle of josh's teeth another
popular fan theory is that josh either
lost his mind and killed mike and
heather or that
mike and josh both conspired to kill
heather together
the number of people crewing the
documentary shoot also seems
suspiciously small most camera operators
use assistance
as refilling a 16 millimeter camera is
an involved process
and would be challenging for amateur
shooting in the woods at night not to
mention how heavy all that equipment
would be to carry
did josh and mike purposely go into the
woods with heather alone because they
had more sinister motives
heather's diary recovered under a
hundred year old cabin by an archaeology
class a year after the filmmakers went
missing
has some interesting notes on the
behavior of her crew the journal details
suspicions that mike and josh aren't
sleeping
the creative team when describing how
they communicated with the actors to
avoid direct contact
explained that one of their notes read
josh is slowly losing his mind
mike also admits to throwing away the
team's map in what can only be a
possible act of sabotage
a deleted scene reveals that josh
actually crumpled up the map
and threw it on the ground before mike
destroyed it meaning both men were lying
to heather about not knowing its
whereabouts
in the curse of the blair witch it's
explained that rustin parr's house was
burned by townspeople following his
arrest
so how were mike and heather able to run
around a house that had been burned to
the ground in the 1940s
how is it that the filmmakers walk south
from a river for hours
only to end up in the same place
heather's journal reads
i had the compass out all day all three
of us checked it every five minutes we
were going south
all day there's also the strange fact
that the equipment and footage was found
in the colonial era foundations of a
burned down house
david mercer the archaeology professor
who led his class to the site explains
that even a forensic expert could not
have placed those items without leaving
signs of disturbance
the time warp theory contends that
heather mike and josh hiked into an area
of the woods where time is altered
leading them to hike in circles and to a
time when parr's house is still standing
and that it was parr who killed heather
there while ordering mike to stand in
the corner
this theory is connected to 2016's blair
witch film which wasn't made by the
original filmmakers but
has a concept supported in the blair
witch canon in the original pitch video
for the 1999 movie shown on the show
split screen narration explains that
sections of the black hills area are
lost in time
once entered there is no way out
of all the endings suggested by fans
over the years the interpretation with
the most evidence is that the blair
witch
or a spirit associated with her
possessed the filmmakers
this led them astray and turned them
against each other or used unseen
figures to dispose of them
producer greg hale explains kedward
actually wasn't a witch but she did a
couple of things that kind of made
people suspect her
he told screenrant that kedward was
blamed for witchcraft and
after being banished to the woods quote
she kind of became the conduit for this
thing
as did rust in par in the 40s sanchez
often refers to this power as the entity
which possibly predates human history
and notes
but the responsibility for triggering
the evil falls on human shoulders
eventually
and the film itself depicts some
possible supernatural events
mike is screaming loudly as he runs
through parr's house in the final
minutes of the film
when suddenly his voice cuts off that
leaves us with the knowledge that
whatever lured mike and heather into the
house was capable of controlling mike
silently
hale implied that the entity doesn't
only use kedward to carry out its evil
deeds
saying it just looks for a way to affect
people and do things
in one interview with the townspeople a
resident says what ruston park did with
his victims
stating this he took uh the kids down in
the basement by twos and he made one
face into the corner really and then he
would kill the other one
just when you think you've got the blair
witch project figured out it manages to
throw you another curveball
for all the talk of an entity possessing
ellie kedward rustin parr or any of the
other figures who might be responsible
for torturing the missing filmmakers
the initial burkittsville 7 goes
unmentioned
rock gave the inside scoop to dread
central a few years ago
much debate had gone into the ending of
the film throughout the process
and the final compromise concept was
that the children rustin parr had killed
would have done this
so after heather's camera went down
those of us outside the house were to
run in and gingerly run around as if we
were children who'd been freed
and when we did heather made that final
scream you hear in the movie
that guttural manifestation and we all
ran into the middle of the house and ran
around on the wood floor like idiots
give us the possession theories all day
long we draw the line at creepy spirit
children for our own well-being
don't like that conclusion several years
ago sanchez and myrick confirmed that
when
artisan pressured them to change the
film's ending to make it more definitive
they ended up shooting four
alternate versions that were never used
these very
unsubtle alternate endings range from
seeing mike surrounded by stickman
figures to him being hanged or crucified
they're pretty universally reviled so
it's a good thing artisan decided to
trust the instincts of their filmmakers
myrick said what makes us fearful is
something that's
out of the ordinary unexplained the
first ending kept the audience off
balance it challenged our real world
conventions
and that's what really made it scary
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite horror movies are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one